whether you enjoyed the new Super Mario
movie or not there's one thing we can
all agree on the 1993 version is a
terrifying monstrosity that should be
thrown into the nearest lava pit in
Lethal lavaland I kid you not even the
World Trade Center gets destroyed
that being said I thought it would be
fun to compare the Off the Wall 1993
classic to its 2023 counterpart if you
haven't seen the new movie or just want
to run down to what happens you can
check out my ending explain video which
has tons of Easter eggs in it which I'll
leave a link to in the comments below of
course the obvious difference is that
the 93 version is live action and new
version animated but a lot of people
forget that the 93 version actually
starts with its own animated segment
depicting the extinction of the
dinosaurs you see while the new version
doesn't even attempt to explain how a
pipe underneath Brooklyn New York
transports the brothers into a
completely different Universe the 93
version has this whole backstory on how
the meteor that killed the dinosaurs
also created two parallel universes ours
where we evolved from monkeys and Dino
Hatton where they evolved from dinosaurs
believe it or not there's no Princess
Peach in this version rather a different
princess named Daisy but unlike the game
where she's the princess of sarasaland
here she's the rightful heir to dino
Hatton which king Koopa has taken over
she's even born out of an egg don't ask
me how that works this is King Koopa
played by Dennis Hopper who surprisingly
is never mentioned as Bowser throughout
the film but we'll get more into him in
a bit the Mario Brothers in both movies
are struggling plumbers with a lousy
truck that barely gets them around the
city both Marios have to contend with a
rival business in the animated version
It's a form and Spike while in the live
action it's a corrupt businessman by the
name of Anthony scapelli spike is also a
character who appears in the live-action
version but he's one of King koopa's
Cousins slash henchmen he appears
alongside Iggy another henchman who's
adapted from the game another key
difference is Mario's Family in the
live-action version Mario's family is
dead or at least that's what's implied
and Mario has to raise Luigi on his own
in the animated version they have a big
family that just doesn't approve of
their struggling business so when a huge
pipe bursts in both versions it's kind
of their way to prove themselves to the
world this is where our adventure begins
for both movies in the animated version
a magical pipe acts as an
interdimensional portal transporting
Mario and Luigi to this new universe
while the live action version it's a bit
more complicated Mario and Luigi are
knocked out by Spike and Iggy who have
orders from King Koopa to capture
Princess Daisy and retrieve this
meteorite fragment Bowser's goal in this
movie is to use the fragment to merge
his world and R so he can destroy
humanity and take over as king as we'll
see in the animated movie Bowser's goal
is much more akin to the games where he
wants to marry Princess Peach while the
portal to this new dimension in the
animated version is a pipe in the live
action it's this creepy wall which when
transported into provides a truly
terrifying experience when compared to
its animated counterpart in the animated
version Mario and Luigi are separated
but here the two arrive at Koopa square
and Dino Hatton essentially the parallel
version of Times Square in Manhattan
this is definitely a stark contrast to
the vibrant Mushroom Kingdom we see in
the new version however there are
mushroom elements sprinkled throughout
the set trust the fungus Dino Hatton is
played by a fungus that takes over the
land
this fungus is said to be a curse from
the former King in retaliation for being
usurped by King Koopa that's right he's
been de-evolved in the fungus and now
he's wreaking his revenge on the city
just like the animated version which has
tons of Easter eggs from the game so too
does Dino Hatton we see shops like
thwomp Stompers bullet bills kinokupa
Cinema and Hammer Brothers tattoos there
are even wiggler signs on top of the
taxis in both versions Bowser wants to
stop Mario but it's in the 93 version
that he offers a 2000 gold Koopa coin
Bounty for his arrest the brothers will
eventually get arrested alongside toad
yes and this is the lime action version
of toad who only has about two minutes
of screen time before he's devolved into
this terrifying creature a Goomba a big
aspect of the live-action film is
evolution or should I say Devolution
Bowser has constructed this machine that
can devolve its victims millions of
years into the past turning them into
Goombas basically mindless followers of
King Koopa there are Goombas in the
anime version but they're given little
to no screen time and certainly don't
look as terrifying as this Mario and
Luigi are able to escape King Koopas in
a wild car chase no Mario Kart style
Escape here which may be because the
script for the movie was written before
Mario Kart was released in 1992. there
is however a tunnel that reads kupahari
desert which I thought was pretty fun
Daisy just like Princess Peach has a
murky origin story having been dropped
off as a baby outside a nunnery her
mother the queen escaped Dino Hatton
when King Koopa usurped the throne and
fled to Brooklyn to save her daughter so
Daisy grew up in Brooklyn even though
she's of Royal Blood From Another
Dimension Peach knows even less about
her Heritage just that she was found by
the Toads as a child and raised by them
to become their Queen the live action
version does have a freaky looking Yoshi
which Bowser calls a pet of the royal
family we briefly get a shot of Yoshi's
in the animated version but based on the
post-credits scene the actual green
Yoshi that we've come to know and love
won't appear until a sequel one
character that doesn't make an
appearance in the animated version is
Bertha a bouncer at the boom boom bar
based on the fish introduced in Super
Mario Brothers 3. Bertha is a member of
the cheap cheap family which is a
smaller version of a fish that appears
on their way to Donkey Kong in the
animated version Mario and Luigi start
off in their iconic uniforms but it's
not until three quarters of the way
through the live action that they
randomly steal these from a locker the
live-action version also has a character
named Lena who's not from the games at
all she acts as Bowser's right-hand man
but for the most part she's incredibly
useless so Mario and Luigi continue
their adventure to save Daisy but along
the way finds several other missing
brooklynite women who Koopa was
kidnapping
girls from Brooklyn yeah and how could I
forget the mattress luge sequence
scared top that so their mattress goes
flying through the air and they make it
right back to dino Hatton where King
Koopa holds them at gunpoint fortunately
Mario uses a Bullet Bill at way larger
version of which can be found in the
animated version locks it into his shoe
and sends Bowser flying
foreign
Bowser doesn't have his trademark flame
breath in this movie so they give him
this sort of flame spitting gun and
while Luigi takes the girls back to
Safety in Brooklyn Mario and Bowser have
their final confrontation but Mario has
a trick up his sleeve of a bomb those
small little bombs which are featured in
the background in the animated version
but before it can explode that no good
Lina tries to meld the Two Worlds not
knowing that only Daisy has the power to
do so each version has both worlds
colliding but I gotta say the live
action one is far less climactic and one
of the weirdest things here is that
Bowser uses his Devolution gun on
scapelli which turns him into a monkey
but instead of the surrounding crowd
shrieking in Terror at what just
happened everyone just laughs
foreign
Bowser then turns his gun on Mario who
puts his trust in a mushroom for some
reason which somehow devolves into a
larger mushroom which Shields him don't
ask me how it works it's completely
insane now this world melding only lasts
for a few moments before Mario and
Bowser are transported back to dino
Hatton likely because Luigi and Daisy
are meddling around with a meteor
fragment that connects the Two Worlds
Mario uses the Devolution gun on Bowser
and we get to see him in his dinosaur
form a little different than what he
looks like in the animated version
Bowser continues to devolve all the way
into a pile of goo where in the animated
version he's turned small and imprisoned
at Peach's castle one thing the animated
version has very little of in comparison
to the live action is romance especially
for Mario in fact it's Luigi who falls
for Daisy since Mario is already dating
someone named Daniela but both versions
leave the possibility open for a sequel
just three weeks after saving their Two
Worlds Daisy comes in like Luigi Mario
Daisy you gotta come with me I need your
help I guess really hit the fan
after Bowser left with both versions out
I have to give my vote to the animated
version as the superior Mario film I
found it more faithful to the source
material on just an all-around enjoyable
Adventure compared to the absolute
Insanity of its live-action counterpart
but what did you think which Mario movie
Rings Supreme and would you like to see
Hollywood try to take a stab at another
live-action remake let me know in the
comments below thanks for watching
everyone and be sure to like And
subscribe and for more bad takes you can
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at
thinkstoryyt until next time remember
foreign